donc un hommage à G
à on faire une interview par amour c'est
normal ah
[Musique]
d'accordou moi je suis je suis B
jeis je vous êtes
B même en israë carère cette petite
lo bien alors par amour estce que vous
pourriez arrêter de
chanter h
oui non c'est vrai vraim ou si vous
demandez d'arrêter de chanter vous le FZ
non dire qu'il me le demanderait pas
mais si je devais faire une famille et
que ça ça me ça me ça serait contre
contre ça oui j'arrêterai ah d'accord h
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous exiler en Nouvelle-Zélande non
parce que je vais habiter en Israël et
lui aussi donc c'est comme ça ouais
ouais ça c'est mais là dès qu'Esmeralda
sera fini va retourner là-bas ouais
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous faire refaire les
seins je je les connais pas j'en ai pas
besoin vousz pas besoin si vous disez je
veux que tu es les sein de Talia par
exemple ou de bon ça prouverait qu'il
m'aime pas vraiment pour moi mais mais
bon non non
non moi ce que je fais c'est pour lui
parce qu'il regarde l'émission je suis
sûr et je veux savoir que vous feriez
pour lui par exemple la fameuse question
clole de Courau est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à embrasser 100 fois
ces chaussettes sales oui ah il a de la
chance le garçon il y a pas d'hésitation
he c'est un ou franc ceant on a fait
Eveline B est d'accord aussi oui oui oui
j'ai ça ça elle le fait assez souv c'est
assez chouette d'ailleurs est-ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à prendre 20 kg
parce qu'il aime les
Rubins parce que je m'aimerais pas moi
après donc je l'aimerais pas lui ça va
20 tu peux 20 20 c'est énorme c'est
beaucoup mais ça ti ça ti bien parce que
tu as tu as très beau format de visage
un touttit peu
r ah il per pas une minuteouis il dit
que c'est lamentur visage on sait qu'il
pense gros cul tu vois c'est là où il
est
voilà tu
VO c'est lamentable c'est lamentable
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
cacher le corps de quelqu'un qu'il vient
de tuer manger
oui oui à le manger non mais manger non
mais à le cacher oui il est très aimé
quand je pense que là-bas il va au put
c'est incroyable
ah mavaise
langue alors est-ce que par amour vous
accepteriez qu'il est une maîtresse non
vous l'aimez pas alors
si comme ma
femmeis d'accord avec votre femme
d'accordel am ça la rendit heureux pas
du tout plus ma absolument pas donc par
amour vous seriez pas prête à vivre à
tro avec la maîtresse par exemple
pourtant dans un kibbo là c'est pas mon
truc non il y a de la place ouais c'est
vrai mais non non les clubs échangistes
non pas mon truc non plus par amour hein
non avec la maîtresse non ah on arrive
attention on arrive à la question de la
fiche 69 mesdames messieurs
69 et là je me méfie parce que c'est
vous qui me posez une question voy
comment vous êtes je suis prêt à tout
alors
Alan est-ce que vous avez des rêves que
vous avez pas encore accomplis et quels
sont-ils comme rêve oui j'aimerais bien
produire un film de longmétrage ah voilà
pas le réaliser parce que j'en serais
sûrement pas capable mais le produire
oui ça me plairait de faire du long
métrage voilà d'accord un peu dans dans
le milieu des boîtes
échangistes c'est normement vous devriez
être d'accord je sais pas moi mais bon
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
devenir son esclave sexuel
oui ah bravo voilà voilà F
bien est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à arrêter de fumer je fume pas à
commencer à fumer non
bon oui oui ou non j'aime c'est pas bon
pour la voix bon si en plus je dois
arrêter de chanter et commencer à fumer
prendre 20 kg non je oui apparemment
vous l'imez dites la caméra
regardezim
voil la
nouvellealdaor le retour de notreame de
Paris